The word to give in Spanish is dar.
Dar.
Good.
I give is doy.
So it's like boy ending O Y.
DOI.
Good.
I give it.
Lod doi.
Good.
I give them.
Los doi.
Good.
And what if there were feminine things that you were giving?
Las doi.
Good.
How would you say he gives
Da he gives emphasizing he El da El da good and she gives
Good.
How do you say they give?
Eyostan.
Good.
Eostan.
Or elas for feminine.
Eyas tan.
Good.
You informal give?
Dus and if we wanted to emphasize this you
Tutas.
Good.
The word for something we said was algo.
Algo.
So how would you say he's giving me something?
He's giving me something.
El me da algo.
Good.
El meda algo.
They give me something.
Me dan algo.
Good.
Now if you want to say they give it to me, they give it to me.
In Spanish you will just say they give me it.
The personal word me is going to come first and then it is going to come and the position where they go, we know this already.
So how would you say they give me it, they give it to me
Me lo dan.
Very good.
And now emphasize or clarify.
Eyos melodan.
Good.
Or eyas, if they were female they.
Eyas melodan.
Good.
We said that with some future context
We don't need to use the future.
So if you want to say I will give it to you tomorrow, you can just say I give it to you tomorrow.
Let's talk informally.
So informally, how will you say I give you it tomorrow?
Te lo doi manjana.
Te lo doy manana.
Very common
Very Spanish sounding sentence Telodoi Maniana I give you it tomorrow.
Sounds strange in English, but perfect Spanish Telodoi Maniana
How would you say are you giving it to me tomorrow?
And then speak formally.
So complicated sentence in English, are you giving it to me tomorrow?
All we have to do in Spanish is just work out who's doing what
We work out who's doing what and to who and we build that.
It's very simple in Spanish.
Complicated sentence in English but not in Spanish.
Talking formally.
Are you giving it to me tomorrow?
Well it's da.
That's the first thing you should work out.
Good.
Me lo da.
Mayana.
Good.
Now what if we wanted to emphasize you?
Are you
Giving it to me tomorrow.
And usted can come in the beginning or the end.
Yeah.
So usted melodam
Mañana.
Usted me lo da mañana.
These words usted yo el ey are extremely flexible for different emphasis.
Again, it's not something we want to
teach here because that those nuances of emphasis change depending on the dialect and it's something that you pick up in real life because where people move it around is accompanied with a change in the voice and hand expressions and you understand
in this case intuitively, which is emphatic.
You guys is usted but plural.
Now if the word ends in a consonant in Spanish, you don't just add s, you add es
So how would it sound, you guys?
Ustedes.
Good.
So now let's say, will you guys give it
To us tomorrow.
So again, we just want to work out who's doing and to who or to what are they doing, and then we can construct it.
So are you guys giving it to us tomorrow
So it's tan.
Yes.
And it's nos and it's still lo.
Good.
Nos lo tan manana.
Now this could mean you guys
Or they give it to us tomorrow.
Now what if you wanted to clarify that it was you guys
Good.
How do you say I want to give?
I want to give.
Good.
I want to give you it.
Talking informally.
Informally.
I want to give it to you.
Quiero tas.
Work out the verbs first.
I want to give.
Work that out first.
Oh Quiro dar.
Good.
To give you is something else.
It's not you give.
I want to give kierotar it to you.
So it's lo and it's te.
Good.
And in what order did they come?
It's te lo kierotar.
Good.